nous avons voulu cette semaine donner la
parole à une minorité agréable et
intéressante
les poules piste monsieur cory zier
bonjour messieurs corrosive vous êtes
depuis 1975 président des poules piste
de france 76 précisément oui et alors
quel est le but de votre association
c'est une excellente question je vous
remercie de me l'avoir posée la pf c'est
à dire l'association des bouddhistes de
france a été créé dans le but de mettre
en contact et de faire se rencontrer
aussi souvent que faire se peut les
françaises et les français qui aiment à
se mettre un poulpe sur la tête
et comment devient ampoules piste
excellente question
on devient poule piste on devient poulpe
ispahan par besoin d'identité par besoin
de de se reconnaître soi même par besoin
de se reconnaître pour lutter contre
cette société et robotisée c'est cela le
moulin blanc et pour le pis par besoin
de ce rock nous est alors en dehors de
ce facteur de reconnaissance quels sont
les autres avantages du poulpe isme
c'est une excellente question ils sont
vraiment multiples voyez-vous par
exemple l'été le poulpe est frais et
très agréable à porter en revanche
l'hiver il constitue un rempart très
très efficace contre toutes les
intempéries le froid la neige et puis
par ailleurs grâce à saluant ce naturel
le poulpe retient les pellicules les
pellicules disgracieuses dans la
prolifération sauvage pourrait nuire par
exemple au développement d'une idylle
mais on dit aussi que le poulpe isma des
effets bénéfiques sur la santé alors
qu'en est il exactement c'est une
excellente question je vous remercie de
me l'avoir posée c'est tout à fait exact
vous faites allusion j'imagine l'action
analgésiques du pourrissement cas de
céphalées oui oui
alors si permis
les gens qui nous regardent ce soir
certains souffrent de maux de tête aux
migraines diverses qu'ils fassent
l'expérience suivante alors vous mettez
un poulpe sur la tête et vous absorbez
vous avez les deux aspirines et vous
verrez les le résultat tout à fait
stupéfiant alors que si vous faites le
contraire
le résultat est nul et puis alors enfin
le poulpe le poulpe est constitué un
excellent remède facile contre le bruit
oui vice-président et alors vous aussi
madame vous êtes poule piste depuis
toujours ou là là non vous allez rire
mais jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ans j'étais
végétarienne authentique
puis j'ai rencontré georges l'un des
pionniers du pool piste et il vous a
converti non non il m'a toujours laissé
libre de mes opinions seulement lorsque
nous allions au cinéma ou bien au
restaurant ou simplement quand nous
étions invités chez des amis j'avais
l'impression qu'il était un peu triste
d'être le seul apporter un plus sur la
tête
et puis l'idée que le jour du mariage je
puisse arriver tête nue
je crois qu'il avait un petit peu honte
de moi j'ai cédé et vous ne le regrettez
pas c'est une excellente question je
vous remercie de la vieux reposer je
vais vous dire je ne pourrais même pas
supporter l'idée que je puisse vivre
sans un poulpe sur la tête
mais quelle explication donnez-vous est
là mais c'est un animal très affectueux
on s'y attache terriblement très
affectueux et très obéissants regard des
sultans pas bougé
ah oui non c'est impressionnant
[Musique]
doucement sultan doucement voilà des
animaux d'où une association paisible et
pourtant les poules piste dérange
puisqu'on continue à leur refuser
l'entrée des plages alors à ce propos
écoutons ce qu'a à dire la présidente
des noms poule piste de france nous
disons que le spectacle de ces personnes
qui se promènent sur nos plages le
poulpe a l'air est un spectacle
révoltant pour nos enfants et même pour
les adultes
en conséquence de quoi nous demandons
aux municipalités du littoral de france
de bien vouloir nous montrer ce qu'elles
ont dans leur pantalon en leur
interdisant les bords de mer vous
comprenez pourquoi
devant cette intolérance qui frise
l'apartheid nous demandons nous
demandons quoi nous demandons instamment
aux pouvoirs publics de nous réserver
des espaces où nous pourrons enfin nous
et battre et poulpe est librement parce
que c'est un droit
et parce que nous l'exigeons c'est le
mélodieux c'est un excellent poult je
vous remercie de me l'avoir posée eh
bien nous espérons que votre appel sera
entendu
la semaine prochaine nous vous parlerons
d'une autre minorité agréable et
intéressante
les rhinos et rocistes à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]